and then the question was what would be
the the new religion to supplant and
subvert Christianity the religion of the
age of Aquarius well as we enter the age
of Aquarius we have a new religion in
this tweet David Rosado explains the
great awokening is a global phenomenon
no evidence it started in the U.S media
analysis of 98 million news articles
across 36 countries quantifies exception
state-controlled media from China Russia
Iran using wokeness terminology to
criticize and mock the West
and here we see in this image
you can see the rise of terminologies
related to transphobia homophobia
transphobic islamophobia every one of
these countries even the Congo
experienced a major spike in social
justice rhetoric the one thing that
correlates social media simply put when
the AI is created and shared it
functions to serve human emotion and
anger gets the most shares